[Music]
that's 10 things
what's up i'm little baby these are my
essentials
[Music]
my main and first essential will be god
or the most high
and i say that because i wouldn't be
able to do nothing that i'm doing
without them
so my next essential item would be money
so that's that
my next essential item would be my kids
i wasn't able to be here with me today
but i have each one of them on the chain
picture them on a chain so my kids and
my family will be my necessity
most high gotta get the money first take
care of my kids
my next essential item my phone my phone
charger the majority of my life is on
the phone so
i gotta keep the phone sometimes i keep
two phones but i lose one so much so
majority of the time
i just keep one phone and a good charger
so the phone in the charger is
essentials that i definitely need
all right food
my favorite food is hot wings right now
the best hot wings in atlanta all right
the west end mall i love them
the lady in there who i actually call my
mom she sells the hot wings she's been
working there since i was young
hot one is definitely my essential lemon
pepper with mild sauce both of them
together now lemon pepper sprinkles
lemon pepper sauce with the mild sauce
everyday routine
my car keys my house keys all the keys
to my life
favorite car that i own right now would
have to be to never get it
car not the truck that would be my
favorite car right now
but depending on my day i have a
different favorite car every day
today
maybe 10 cars white air force one
i would say i'm addicted but this is
probably a little more than addicted
just like a way of life for me
prepare white out for as long as i keep
preparing while first ones
any season even when they're not in the
stores i gotta have
a lot of pair of white air force one
gotta have size nine
in case you to buy me a pass on my next
essential item is like a package
underwear my tank tops
my t-shirts i mean i never wear the same
underwear t-shirts a tank top i changed
my t-shirt my tank top
and my underwear every day and most of
the time i be on a roll when i'm out of
town
so whenever i go i try to take like two
per day
definitely one of my assistants
my next decision would have to be
maybe because of my career me being a
rapper
once i get all this stuff i think i'm
gonna hang it up it's not it
it's fun to me as it used to be but i'm
definitely
definitely still essential you see how
like further down the list it is but
definitely essential i'll show y'all a
couple of chains
i gotta have this box this icebox travel
kit because i got too much jewelry to be
able to like
just throw it in the bag and throw it
somewhere so i got to keep the tray
this is not all my dreams somewhat near
but not all of it
my favorite would have to be icebox i
actually go to icebox
like once a week or something like i got
the best cleaning in the game like
to be having me hand like definitely i
call this my relaxation pack
smack woods a little relaxation
so keep me a relaxation pack i keep a
lot going on throughout the day and
a lot of times i just want to get away
and get a few seconds to myself so
i keep me a relaxation pack definitely
one of my essentials
last but not least my last ascension
would have to be my watches
i got a ton of watches so like i wear a
different watch every day i got like
maybe two or three of these icebox um
watch rolls but i just might bring three
at a time four at a time
travel with all my watches at one time
and this watch actually right here this
is my favorite watch
it's a regular rolex just date this is
the first rolex i ever had
and it was actually a regular just a
regular watch with no diamonds on it
when i first got it
and over the time i probably just built
on the watch like
this probably one of the most expensive
watches i got because
i did it like piece by piece i got one
side bush down another side
another building i probably had four
five dozen i never get rid of this watch
so like
this is my favorite watch so i had to
bring this like this one to my
essentials like
this is the start of baby and i got on
the skeleton ap
make sure i'm going all right your
middles though like i'm gonna let
let's let the watches go but for now
they definitely essential
[Music]
there you have it thanks for watching my
10 essentials and thank you for tuning
in
until next time